I think vm the most important thing
we've got to do is to build more homes
more affordable homes homes in places
people want to live I think one of the
big mistakes the government made a
couple of years ago was to abolish the
presumption that you would build on
brownfield sites first because that's
actually where people want to live in
the cities is where the land is and part
of the reason why the government's been
pretty bad at getting the house building
numbers through is because the
developers are saying well we don't ago
brownfield let's go to the greenfield
land on the edge of the towns and the
cities that's actually where you can
only build expensive houses you run into
big planning problems so the answer is
in the end you can't make housing
affordable for first-time buyers unless
you get more homes being built George
Osborne has said he wants to help people
to save her a deposit and that's fine by
me but you can only afford a deposit and
a mortgage if the house prices are
actually related joke world under the
Labour government in real terms it was
on your watch that I think that in the
early years of the Labour government we
didn't build enough homes I totally
agree when we came in in 1997 there were
loads of houses in our country that
council houses with no bathroom inside
rooms which are leaking we said let's
sort out the existing houses a 19
billion backlog but I don't think we
built enough homes we were turning that
round 10 years ago the financial crisis
clearly has made that harder there's no
question about that but have we at the
moment got a plan to build more homes we
say 200,000 more homes a year by the end
of the decade it's a really difficult
objective I think we can deliver it but
all the quite a big push from government